I know wouldn't do that hey youtubers
it's Charlie and it's time to talk about
the second episode of agents of shield
this time the team is brought in to
investigate a mysterious power source
and if you thought that sounded a lot
like The Avengers tesseract then you
were right they end up finding out that
it's a tesseract powered weapon like the
kind you saw the red skull building and
the original Captain America movie they
basically had to get it back to shield
headquarters but they run into the
Peruvian army
it turns out the leader of the peruvian
army is actually someone who used to
work with Coulson and he probably had a
little bit too much fun with on the job
obviously this being the second episode
in a shield series you know that they're
going to win somehow it's just a matter
of how they're going to solve the
problem Thorin so basically the team
just uses this episode as a Bonnie
experience you basically learned this is
their first full mission as a team
together because the first mission
technically was when they were trying to
get sky the Coulson's storyline in this
episode becomes a lot more prominent he
actually gets a lot of nice action - not
quite on par with the Avengers but
kickin that he delivered to Loki but
still pretty good it's nice to see him
he didn't really do that much in the
first episode but walk around and yell
at people I did like the fact that they
addressed Coulson's collector status
he's basically a collector of nostalgic
items basically the Kommandant played by
Allen or the antagonist of the episode
tells Coulson that he's romanticizing
the past and the episode turns into this
cautionary tale about what happens when
you romanticize the past too much
because obviously she ends up del
crossing him and trying to plain Jack
them the team ends up bonding coming
together not without a few Ming na jokes
which i think is funny I'll address
those later but basically they get rid
of the Peruvians and slingshot the
device into the Sun but during the
process there are some new questions
raised obviously to propel us into the
next episode mostly being that Skye is
still part of rising tide and is still
in communication with her other rising
tide people so it'll be interesting to
see how that's going to come back and
bite her in the ass obviously the red
masks we saw in the promo for episode 3
probably have something to do with that
let's talk about the shipping on this
episode because obviously they were kind
of playing that up in the premiere
between grant and Skye they do have a
bit of a moment but it is cut short by
the Peruvians as grant starts looking
around obviously they're gonna play that
up for comedy I'm sure
I really like the ming-na cavalry jokes
obviously her character Melinda Mae is
still very mysterious to us right now
we obviously know something happened in
Bahrain she obviously went into
Berserker rage and killed a ton of
people and is now in this kind of Rambo
state like in Rambo 3 where he basically
gave up violence and became a pacifist
that's really just reinforced when she
gets super upset at Coulson for making
her fight but later in the episode we
actually learned that she is something
of a shield legend and then they call
her the cavalry like when you say
calling the cavalry in her case they're
basically talking about her as a person
so if you remember in my video for
episode 1 I talked about her being like
the Jane of the team like the Firefly
Jane of the team I think that's really
just hammered home in this episode when
you just see her break her wrist it was
really meant as a joke and just to show
how badass she was but let's talk about
the biggest moment of the episode it was
not the episode itself but that little
post-credits bit I feel like in true
Marvel fashion they saved the best for
last
don't run away yet make sure you TiVo
all the way through the ads so obviously
if you've seen the episode you know
Samuel Jackson was in and in full-on
Nick Fury mode I'll downgrade your ass
to a Winnebago son let me know what you
think of his appearance I really thought
it was a pretty good use of him I didn't
really expect to see him till later in
the series but obviously since the show
is so early in this run and they really
want to win over new viewers and
existing Marvel fans they want to use
some of their big guns early personally
I thought the episode as a whole was
actually better than the premiere
there's a lot more action it was a lot
tighter and obviously I think it's gonna
get even better once they get over this
hump of becoming a team because
obviously there's a lot of infighting
and bickering but what happens when a
team really comes together that's when
the real action starts so that's what
I'm really excited to see but I'm
assuming that they're gonna spend the
next couple of episodes still kind of
trying to mesh but let me know what you
think what were your favorite parts of
the episode obviously I'm guessing the
Nick Fury cameo was at least one of
those things but obviously the Coulson
backstory was a lot of fun especially
seeing him be a bit of a ladies man and
a badass in the episode so next week
I'll be posting my episode 3 video be
sure to subscribe to get it we're gonna
get to see our first supervillain it's
titled the asset and the name of the
asset is actually the person that ends
up turning to graviton in the comics I
talk a little bit about it in a preview
that I did last week which you can watch
here and you can click here to watch all
my other agents of shield videos thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow high fives
you